it must be great to be bad thank you I'm
blushing super hard under the man we're
telling a story then probably no other
Batman movie can do a story about
whether Batman can change and that's not
something that any other Batman movie is
probably going to try to do I hope
people are entertaining have fun we
really tried to make a movie that was it
took what we've done in the lego movie
and kind of expanded on Batman's world
visually it's like a really it's kind of
a spectacle of a film there's a lot
going on a great animators really
amazing artist who created a beautiful
world I wanted this thing to feel like a
giant basil of go-go's painting come to
life and when you see it in imax you
actually can like just feel the
saturation feel to end the sound is
incredible there are so many great big
kind of epic set pieces of the film
right off the bat and the shots are
really a dynamic sort of you know
overhead with the Batmobile and going
through the city and explosion it's
really pretty amazing it's great
filmmaking you can see more in imax I
think busy if you you like stuff in the
background and you want to sort of hunt
for things that I've put in the
background of movie you're actually
going to be able to see a lot of very
Easter eggs and that sort of thing in
the movie in imax why did you build this
thing with only one seat because last I
checked I only had one but